whatever
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up
can you hear me yeah I can hear you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's going on you guys Lord addicting
King David here coming at you with
another r r with the Lords we got a
pretty stacked show for you guys uh
first off uh well how you been doing
King you know we just got through
recording a couple episodes of Attack on
Titan you know we got we got that that
attack on Titan reaction coming for you
guys here soon
I'm doing fantastic especially after
watching Attack on Titan I think Attack
on Titan is finally starting to live up
to the lofty praise that I hear from all
these anime anime dudes
um it's uh getting to that point where
it's it's luring me in it it lulled me
to sleep uh it made me didn't don't like
you know certain characters that are
turning out to be something pretty
special so yeah I'm really respecting it
before before I wasn't respecting it no
you know still holding holding uh Naruto
way above it even holding Dragon Ball Z
way above it but we're gonna get a
chance to get into it and not even going
to none of my bakkie uh you know
stuff so I'll let God awful
talking about that god-awful show I see
you
Butch what's good but yeah it starts at
five o'clock you know we we was there we
were just you know getting stuff ready
you know prepping and stuff you know
yeah plus uh you know cut like it was
like an hour ago we were watching the
attack on Titan thing uh I would like to
to finish that last episode here soon so
I could start posting those if you want
to do it after this we can do it after
this if you like yeah it's just one
episode it's like uh like 20 minutes
long yeah King is on the last episode of
season one guys the last episode I think
it's going to be a very interesting uh
conclusion
what's funny about
me doing because I don't really do the
reactions with them I'm kind of just
there to manage things and like to give
like like funny input of someone like
pretty much someone speaking from the
future because I've seen I'm caught up
to date with the attack on Titan keep in
mind the last uh the the newest episode
that that's on our uh our patreon like
it's like an hour and some long I
reacted to one episode like an hour and
like 20 minutes long I'll catch up to
him one day yeah one day one day
uh but you know first off I want to
thank everyone for coming through man R
and R with the Lords uh today we have a
good show for you guys man we're gonna
be talking about Creed Three King
wouldn't watch that he's gonna give you
his uh synopsis on that uh I I kind of
got a little bit of a early bars at iron
lore's podcast this week so it's going
to be interesting to hear his opinion on
that today we uh we're gonna talk about
my Mandalorian there's another season
that that just aired First episodes
season three and then we're gonna talk
about The Last of Us Part uh At Last of
Us season one part uh episode eight uh
there's one episode left in that and I
think there's going to be some
interesting man
but you know I think what what we should
do first king
let's just go ahead and get straight
into it man you know I think last of us
is definitely the show we need to start
it with uh at this point we guys know
you know there's a lot of people that
come here for the last of us thing uh
next week that will be ending and I
think we'll well you know what we'll do
king I will get together a panel podcast
and we'll have a legit spoiler class on
the entire season okay on patreon
that'll work that'll work we can sit
there we can actually dive deep into all
these episodes and talk about what we
like what we didn't like what was good
what wasn't good
um much like this episode
yeah I actually you're gonna be uh
you're gonna be surprised with me with
this episode all right so let's go ahead
and start it man uh the the episode
clearly ends with Joel
he's injured
um you know we we see that the the
episode before
uh-huh you said this episode ended with
Joe being injured yeah yeah well it
started again it begins all right
what happened he's still injured you
know um uh Ellie is nursing him back to
life and I I think there's a lot of
interesting stuff going in this this
episode
I I want your general idea of this
episode first like you know let's start
with just your overall perspective of
you know the game to the movie uh to the
TV show I'm gonna be honest with your
expectations going into this episode was
because a lot of people this particular
episode was gonna make it and break it
kind of moment because there's a lot
that goes into this next episode uh for
the the people in the chat they're right
now on the part where you know you place
Ellie in the game and you go you know
find supplies and stuff for Joel now I'm
gonna be honest with you
um I don't remember it all that much
because remember when I brought the
Remake well no it was the I think it was
the Remake whatever the upres version of
it um
I didn't get a chance to play it I had I
had it sitting there and then I went and
got the remaster after playing the demo
right the little brief part of the demo
so Brooke I'm still
having to play this game that I played
so many years ago and
I never felt like the last of us the
first one was as memorable to me as a
second you know Last Quest too so again
I'm remembering bits and pieces of it
and comparing it to the game I can't
really do it because I won't do it any
justice but
as it as an episode
um
the stuff that I do remember I do
remember that they met some people that
were into some nefarious things
um Joe was injured and she had to you
know go and and heal him but from that
point it became a little bit vague
um so this this episode is I I
thought at the end of this episode that
you would be very happy
because this episode
guy gave attic what attic was looking
for uh human on human violence yeah and
I would I'm still nitpicking a little
bit on the episode but for the most part
you know they they showed
what it's like to be an apocalypse world
like and and I feel the tension that was
going on I feel people knew the stakes
you know we'll get into a little bit you
know there was a lot of torturing stuff
going on I felt like there was real life
Stakes up and not just oh you know we I
just the previous episodes I I didn't
feel that but this particular episode
really felt like there were Stakes going
on felt like there was actual you know
beef going on felt like there was danger
at every corner it felt like an actual
apocalypse and guess what king
another episode where they stick closer
to the game than going off of the off
the books and guess what it's another
highly rated episode to everyone else
I'ma say this
I've always felt the tension
except for the episode where
um Frank and this guy
um I've always felt attention always
felt the dystopian World always felt the
oppression I always felt the fear
I think you felt this more because of
the human on human violence I think that
is that that's what would happen in a
real exact same area going on in an
apocalypse that's the only penis that
this this episode all from other
episodes was the fact that there was
wonton violence on humans and they're
still sticking to the script they're
still not showing blood like they're
supposed to this show after effect blood
on you they don't show it happening yeah
and that's that's my nitpick it's like
okay yo uh I'm I'm glad that they're
they are starting to actually show the
violence that this world is because this
world is a violent world it's not a nice
world it's not a kind world it's a very
violent survival type of world and this
is one of the very first episodes
including episode five one and two
because uh those are my favorite
episodes that that is showing that human
on human violence that when you you put
a bunch of people with no form of law
enforcement no form of control that
people will go off the rails ninety
percent of people probably walking
around do some crazy stuff if they
wasn't feeling well it wouldn't evolve
into a religious structure and going to
Old World sensibilities
of course this is what this episode was
about it was uh they devolved into old
world religion old world sensibilities
uh uh Monarch type system where one
person was either elected or got in by
you know force and he controlled the
group through fear and manipulation this
was this whole episode to be honest with
you and David was uh um
uh was an ideal
character for this
the way he handled uh people that were
Superior to him in strength people that
were Superior to him in numbers and some
people that you may think that was
probably
um smarter than him
he outfoxed them he controlled them
manipulated them and he was
using these tactics
to gain an advantage in a place where he
didn't have an advantage and and I
thought that was very good with this
episode I really like the character of
David David is the the preacher teacher
uh Slash
um ruler of this small group and the the
way he manipulates the situation uh Keys
into more of how the episode was going
to pan out and I think it was good
because if you can get people to do the
stuff that he was enforcing it's
absolutely nuts and there are more of
them so for him he had to be some form
of great manipulator to uh achieve that
goal but right now we have tip tip whale
with the five dollar Super Chat I
believe look at it would be a Raider if
we came to a post-apocalyptic world
because he's looking for all the smoke
definitely 100 I believe addict would be
a lone killer
he would have uh uh you would you
wouldn't find his bunker uh he would
have trip wires all over the place it
wouldn't be a town that you will be able
to walk in and find his his he would be
the real Frank yes yes yeah underground
bunker that only he knows the the
entrance and the exit two would various
booby traps and stuff yeah yeah he he's
well thought out yeah yeah I mean so you
know I I like this episode I I really
was vibing with this episode I felt like
there was good pacing here I felt like
the actors did very good like this this
episode was good and you know once
you'll be hold on one second attic
please listen to what I gotta say
uh about Creed Creed is going to be the
the I don't know the second topic or
whatever but
um please please hold off until you hear
what I gotta say sorry got it
so you know that that was that was
pretty much my you know synatics when it
comes to this so what what did you like
about the episode like in particular I
love the fight that individually
each one had
I love the fight that Ellie had I love
the choices that Ellie had to make
um Ellie messed up a lot she messed up a
lot but this is her first time in the
wild but she handled herself like a
champ uh tell me how when she took that
horse out of that that uh
she took that horse out of the the
garage I knew that that was done I knew
that thing was over well I I didn't
think in my head that they would kill a
source of
um food Revenue like you know to kill a
horse
is idiotic
in the sense that that horse can take
you to kill other animals and drag back
larger prey right and instead of you
trying to hustle back bringing this prey
back but regardless of what that's a
plot hole that I found in it I thought
it was ignorant in in what they did but
at least fight at least fight her first
fight was to find some form of food and
um that's our first fight and she went
out there she did that successfully
she wounded a dare she did that
successfully and she was you know trying
to get that back to Joe and she would
have got it back to Joe because she she
uh would have got the horse would have
dragged it back and they would have
chopped they would have they would have
been fine but you know she knows and
she's not ignorant Joe has an affection
and I thought it was a good bartering
technique that she used with the guy uh
to say give me medicine form I thought
that was great uh so she handled herself
this she's a little naive in certain
aspects because she's a child but the
the mentality of Ellie is is she's on
she's she doesn't trust easy and she's
going to give you a hard way
Joel's fight Joel's fight was first to
stay alive
then Joel's second fight was to
to get to Ellie and secure her
and I and I believe that first we got a
chance to see exactly who Joel is my
wife said oh that's a bad MF
he is a bad MF and I said now you're
gonna see exactly who Joel is Joel is
that that you want in your corner this
did feel a lot more like the the actual
TV the game Joel like yeah you know and
I'm starting at first you know what's
funny king and you know we'll probably
disagree with this but
it seemed like we've we do nothing but
disagree on this particular TV show but
um going into this in episode one I was
convinced that
that Pedro is going to be going to do
Joel Justice and that uh Bella was gonna
do Ellie not justice but now
going into episode eight it's flipped I
actually think she's doing a great Ellie
and he's performing an average to below
average Joel
I wouldn't go with you on that but um uh
I think he's doing a great job I think
he's working with the material that was
given to him but that even though that
most of my issues is probably the script
that was handed to him right he's still
playing it so
and I know you don't care about the the
who what and whys you just want to know
about the outcomes you your your bottom
line dude
because my issues isn't a hundred
percent Pedro obviously right there's
multiple people that have led to this
outcome I'm blaming all of them they all
get in the smoke but Pedro is the is the
one out in front so he's got it yeah
I like this episode of Pedro I like
I like when he got up to Ellie after you
know she did her fight and she and he
scooped up and he said you know I got
you baby girls me
this is this is this is the connection
part
that we were trying to get to this is
this is the part where uh the parental
guidance of of of Joel kicks in this is
this is the part where he becomes that
that
that father you understand what what a
father is supposed to be a father
supposed to be a protector a provider uh
that that that shield from the world and
and I seen it there I've seen well I've
seen it in a couple of other episodes so
I seen him doing these things and It
ultimately led up to this because this
guy is stabbed in his goat which her
shooting penicillin into the infected
area okay yeah we're not even gonna go
into that part but
I don't know anything about would that
even do anything I have no idea I I
don't either I said as a child though
like mentally mentally
I think you and I would have probably
shot him in the butt
like she was born after the collapse
she's like yeah she's never been to
hospitals she doesn't know anything like
that
yeah so yeah stuff stuff that's common
sense to us isn't common to her so
she shoots it in an infected area but
Joel is going around with Eternal
Bleeding properly
you know and raging infection fever
whatever and
he manages to take down four guys
Four Guys hog ties two
tortures to
and I guess it's spoiler time
you know well it's been spoiler time for
for the episode
yeah um
I I really is vibing with it man I I
felt it was good you know they showed
while people keep forgetting Joe's
feared in these communities like people
are like oh you know he's not John Wick
no one's asking him to be John Wick no
but Joe was feared in these communities
they had people that was literally
they uh what's more I'm looking for like
loan sharks and stuff scared of Joel so
yeah to repo their money yeah they were
gonna kill tez in the first episode
because they didn't want the
repercussions that Joe found out it was
that it right and that's the funny part
about it she had to convince them not to
kill her because she wasn't gonna tell
Joe
he's like you told Joe he's gonna come
after us he's like I'm going to come
after you so you know um
the episode all right so the mentality
of how
David breaks down you you can break down
everybody in this thing right and when
we find out that they're cannibals
which is obviously you're at the worst
end of society at that point in time
because he's not even burying the people
that died they're eating them
so everybody that they come across that
they fight that they kill that they
they're eating them and and the world
goes full circle when he's sitting there
he's talking to L.A and he's trying to
get her to willingness willingly give
herself over to him so it's not called
ape you know
um you know this this guy
is trying to trick her into coming with
him and and and and being with him
because it was very creepy it was so
creepy but I felt the same creepiness
when he was with the little girl's
father I mean with the little girl who
father died
so you already saw that he was a
predator
all right and he has control over the
herd so that within itself is a
Troublesome situation
now the guy that he had with him
um what was that guy name you remember
the the tall guy that I think his name
was John
um I do have a picture of him this dude
he he's the dude from Fallen Skies
there's a okay there's a uh there's a TV
show that used to be on uh FX it was
about aliens taking over it's actually a
good show you should try to watch it uh
um and you know he's the main character
from it it was like one of those things
where you know go back and forth in that
show they can't even hurt the aliens
like there's a technology can't even
shoot through their armor that's
ridiculous but you know he he clearly
this guy is bigger stronger and more
intelligent
but
don't don't let all that stuff fool you
you know a predator and and a person of
a high IQ can manipulate and can control
a group and he did it he told him yo go
get the medicine
and then you know come back now he he
lied to Ellie told him told her that it
was uh a Four mile hike back and four
mile hike there or whatever to throw her
off or whatever just in case she did
have more people
but at the same time
he knew to get her get the medicine
we're gonna get this horse back because
she's not going to be able to take the
horse she's not even going to be able to
take half of the horse right so get the
medicine she's gonna run out of here and
we can come find her tomorrow we'll just
get the horse back
and it was a deer I mean well I mean the
Dare sorry yeah they got the horse later
they get they did they got the deer
um
and
the guy was like
we gonna do this like he he really
looked at him like he was questioning
his authority
when he pulls them over to the side
earlier when the daughter acts from from
the um the father that was killed from
the raid the Excursion team that they
send out earlier in the the previous
episode and Joe killed that guy
when she was funny they'd be acting like
that dude didn't do anything he did stop
it yeah he he tried he literally stabbed
Joel like he tried to pull him off the
horse and but it's a different story
when
when you're told oh y'all were just
going out there flourishing and going to
get rabbits no y'all hunt people y'all
kill people he was one of the people
that was in the nose so these cannibals
are out there hunting and killing people
maybe the whole group didn't know this
only select a few the people that got to
chop them up the people that got to cook
them yeah you could tell that when she
had he handed that lady in the kitchen
that meat that she
she's like man I don't want to do this
like yeah it's it's it's he's like what
is it she was like what is it and as
long as you have the silent lie between
each other it's venison
okay
you know then you're complicit but
there's there's still that lie but he
told he told the guy right after they
came out of there right after they spoke
to the people he said I sense doubt
and he confronted him one-on-one every
time he confronted that guy he
confronted him one on one so it was
nobody else around
the second time he confronted the guy is
when they had Ellie on the floor and
they was going to kill Ellie
and he was like oh hell no he shot the
gun in the air and he was like no if if
you want Justice go find a guy and go
get Justice y'all to take the horse back
uh to uh so we can cook and eat it
and he grabbed Ellie and took her back
so his level of control eat in a crowd
or solo was at a high peak and I thought
that character the usage of that
character itself was pretty good
um and the way that it took Ellie
to become an apex predator to take that
Predator down
that was a good scene the scene with
with her interacting and fighting
against uh his advances and his uh his
ability to try to control her
even when they also threw her on the
table and was going to try to chop up
into little bitty pieces because he
tried to use the mind games and stuff
like that on her I thought that
interaction between them was really good
I love
acting for the sense of acting where
there's two people that can give
dialogue meaningful dialogue and you can
feel the tension and emotion inside the
dialogue and I thought this episode more
so than a lot more did it best I like
when they threw her on that table seeing
it in this and she's like I've been bit
I'm infected like and then he pulls like
that he's like oh she is impression but
you could clearly see it was held at
that point so I think that's why okay
maybe this was like a like an animal or
something because at that point you're
seeing it completely held she had to
turn by now like it gave her that brief
window
if she waited a split second longer she
let that ability to of Doubt to creep in
and for that guy to question him because
remember this guy's already doubting him
so that Split Second of doubt she was
able to grab that butcher knife
his mindset was yo you're gonna feed us
all
infected meat you about to get everyone
sick well
one she already bit you
two
we ain't eating this infection all right
but use about to turn so either we're
gonna have to deal with two turning
people or what but that that Split
Second of Doubt gave her the window an
opportunity that she needed to take care
of her business
and I thought that was masterful
yeah so you know I think you know that's
pretty much uh all for this episode uh I
would say but you know the thing we got
to do before we pull out of here is put
some popcorn like man what were you
giving this popcorn
for for everything coming full circle I
got to give this a five popcorn
um yeah I gotta give it a five popcorn
because every individual person played
their part to the T even the the towns
folk like the the town
they they played scared they played
afraid
um they played unwilling to go along
with this but they had nothing else it
everybody was acting to the best of
their ability I thought I thought it was
a really really good episode
I had to give it a 5-2 I I think I think
this is the closest that they've been I
would actually say
my favorite episode would be five
still now even though I didn't give that
a five star because I feel like they
messed up in a lot of aspects in episode
five I think there was a lot more going
in five uh but I would say whatever
everything they try to accomplish in
this particular episode they did yeah I
don't you know there's a couple of
nitpicks I could get but for the most
part this is a very solid episode
yeah Alex after this episode after this
show right now I'm gonna probably do the
reaction that's gonna be on the patreon
for the attack on Titan you can go check
that stuff out um that stuff is up there
and I'm going to go to bed because I
work nights so all right so we're done
with that episode
now let's
King let's start on this Mandalorian man
did you did you watch the season three
episode one of course of course what
what was your mindset on this because uh
I got some thoughts man I got some
thoughts
well
the way that the season two ended you
know it felt like a big Disney episode
you know Disney gets a hold of it so
this is their Space Opera Western in
space
and I I like how they're doing it you
know I got to tell you know Pedro Pascal
you know you you are batting a thousand
right now you you're staying in the
Zeitgeist you or the person that
everybody wants to see on H and it's
kind of weird that we went to two
different Pedros episodes back to back
but he's doing it man
um so the Mandalorian episode you know
grogle is back with the Mandalorian and
their traversing space and the
Mandalorian goes back to a Coruscant and
um it's changed the place has changed
everything is different uh he's helped
liberate them from
um
from the oppressive uh Empire you know
uh you have
um Gina garano's uh character they
conveniently written her out of the
script uh you know she got uh hired
someplace else
and uh that's it and moth Gideon has
been taken to a tribunal someplace so we
don't have to worry about moff Gideon
right now so those are two characters is
probably like written off and
we just have to deal with what's going
on with with Mando and why is Mando
there well
in the beginning of the episode you have
the people the the mandalorians that's
on the beach uh doing an initiation to a
new member that's going to be uh walking
the way
and that'll make you like under the
belief that it's like our Mando like
they make you think that you know this
is a past episode like a like passed in
time right because you know when
homegirl coming up there like that it
kind of like okay what's going on here
like because I was generally confused oh
so you thought that it this was uh uh um
a flashback memory well I I knew it
wasn't a flashback memory because of uh
where they were located remember they
they they they lost their home world and
they were scattered Across the Universe
and there uh actually landed in this
small pocket planet that they were on
and they would have never did that in
the water if they know what was lurking
in the water
that tell me when that giant alligator
bopped out the water with a turtle skin
shell on his back he was pretty much
undefeatable to be honest with you
invulnerable on all aspects and each
Mandalorian was trying their hardest
throwing everything at it and nothing
was seeming the Pearson slow him down
stop them at all and um
lo and behold Mando comes flying through
and he shoots him and and you know with
because his ship he has a uh remember he
upgraded from that other ragtab ship to
the um the speed of the speed of fighter
uh and you know gave him two blasts and
then Zoop back around gave him another
two blast and drop the beast but none of
them was happy to see him
none of them they were happy they was
alive but as far as him they're like oh
God yeah you you were exiled you know
you took your helmet off she said you
know you took your helmet off you took
it off off your own volition nobody put
a gun in your head and told you this is
what you had to do but you did this so
in order to atone you have to go you
know babe yourself in in the waters of
Link Minnetonka that's not here anymore
exactly and and he knows that there's a
place for them to find that and and for
them to get to it
so he goes back to the home world and
he talks to the the the Fallen uh
Mandalorian that actually he bested for
the um the the Ebony Blade
and uh
she was like well you go find him you
know he's like what happened to your
army oh they scattered the universe you
go find him and lead him nobody's gonna
listen to me without that blade
and that's pretty much it he just wants
to get back into good graces so he goes
back to Coruscant and then he you know
um wants to get the IG robot to and
that's a battle droid a battle droid
robot
um the IG robot and that's the one
remember they re-uh assigned him to
protect grogal so when they try to bring
him back online he defaulted to his
original programming in trying to kill
groogle and they had to you know bash
his little head in but you see The Tale
of Two Worlds you saw the TV show meet
the movie because uh I think it was the
last uh the last Star Wars film
the the Droid uh fixers the one those
three that that was underground the
little tiny guys
that was funny it was fun
um I like that stuff it was it was a
pretty light-hearted episode really good
but it sets Pace in what's Mando's uh
new objective so his new objective is to
fix his his Droid because that's the
only Droid that he trusts to go into
battle with him he could have many
droids there but he don't trust them and
he and he he brought a kinship to this
Droid so
I think uh I think he's going to retire
on this planet be honest with you I
really do because we got the pirate
scene where the Pirates was chasing them
and they had to stand off and it felt
like a real Western I love the feel of
it because I'm a spaghetti western dude
so the fact that it's in space and they
have light pistols and you know you have
baby grogle it just it's just so cheesy
that it's fun it's fun to me I like I
like the cheesiness of it what about you
sir I think it was a good episode
clearly you know this is the first
episode going into season three I liked
uh you know the the kind-hearted stuff I
like the show and the objective I think
this is going to be one of those things
where that's going to be his objective
but that's not what the overall season
object was going to be yeah like
something's gonna happen between there
here and there or when he gets there
that's going to change the whole
season's parameter uh I'm pretty sure
what's her name supposed to be in this
season cool
um
uh ah Soca Ahsoka yeah yeah she's gonna
be there yeah
The Circle Series they're gonna be yeah
what's funny is I didn't realize how
relevant Ahsoka was oh
like she she's like one of the strongest
Jedi alive yeah she remember she beat
Darth Maul I'm real pissed off at that
but yeah and she she fought Darth Vader
on multiple occasions yeah she's
definitely no joke
but remember she's she's the paddy one
of um Anakin
um
so he trained her uh and I mean he did a
damn good job because she is one of the
best Jedi that we got I still go with
Mace Windu because he mastered both the
light and the dark side that's uh Samuel
Jackson's
um uh Jedi that we still haven't
recovered a body so we still don't know
if the the fan theories is true that he
used the force to uh slow down his
descent from when he was blown out of
the the the window
um from Darth Sidious so we don't know
if he's still alive uh but I'm holding
hope without hope you know hopefully
that he'll make it back and I think
um Disney can see the merchandising in
that you know did you see
the they are interviewing Samuel Jackson
and the only reason he got a purple
lightsaber is because he said he wanted
one he didn't think he'd get one and at
that time there was no real lore behind
the colors of the purple of the Sabers
is just writer red or green and Lucas
like I don't care yeah let's give it to
him and then once they did the purple
one that's when he started riding the
lore behind the the colors of the
lightsabers yep because it became a big
thing uh you know yellow being the
strongest uh this stuff like that the
hardest to master because that that
black saber is supposed to be like a a
midway between a sword and a lightsaber
isn't it yeah because it can actually
fight a lightsaber can't do yes
yes I wonder if they're going to utilize
that a lot like it's very heavy
it's very heavy and it needs blood
it's crazy it has a very wild lore
behind it
and it's like part of the Mandalorian
Laura yeah yeah it's it's it's their
blade to show uh leadership
I have a feeling assist gonna get killed
somewhere with that thing
huh we'll see
that's just my opinion on the matter I
think it's good man I you know
Mandalorian I really enjoyed the first
two seasons I thought they were good a
good show a good seasons
I I probably lean more towards the first
season than the second
uh that's just me uh because I felt like
there was more mystery behind the first
season
and that's the second season
I loved it for the ending with Luke
like
they they needed to show who's a badass
like he's that dude he's the babadook
he's the the the Jedi in the bushes yeah
he was killing Jedi they ain't killing
Luke
y'all couldn't want to kill all you want
into the first season though yeah look
showed up no it was into the second
season
was it wait because the second season he
got broke back no he got grow he got
grogle back at the end of the second
season
wait a second because remember they
didn't want him back it was at the end
it was the second season he got groggle
back it wasn't the first season
I don't know chat correct us yeah yeah
hold on where where did Luke come back
at
I feel like